shy lauff has earned the reputation of a
Hollywood eccentric and in the right
hands this can sometimes translate to
powerful onscreen work this was the case
when his talents were tested in David
A's acclaimed 2014 World War II picture
Fury along with much of the cast lauff
took part in several weeks of military
boot camp alongside a group of Navy
SEALs but lauff who played a tank driver
in the film took his method performance
one step further going so far as to
having one of his teeth removed he
explained on Jimmy Kimmel Live that it
wasn't as easy as one might think saying
it's not like you can go to some dentist
and go in there like hey I want to get
this tooth taken out they were like you
want to do what that doesn't make any
medical sense at all but ultimately
lauff insists that he got it done
because he wanted to add some depth to
the character he added I found a guy in
ra next to a radio shack he didn't ask
too many questions